para el presidente de Francia la reforma
de pensiones es el interés superior de
la nación Emanuel macron defendió su
polémico proyecto que aprobó con la
activación del artículo 49-3 para él una
reforma como esta Nunca es popular y
menos en un país en el que argumentó que
están más acostumbrados a gastar que a
producir aseguró que el aumento de la
edad de jubilación era la única solución
para evitar el colapso del sistema Yo ya
no puedo ser reelegido entonces entre
las encuestas a corto plazo y los
intereses del país El hijo del interés
general del país En qué situación
estaríamos 100.993 o en 2010 mis
predecesores se hubieran detenido y
hubieran dicho no no hacemos reforma
estaríamos en una situación más crítica
Por eso digo que hay que hacerla la
reforma ha enfurecido a la población y
ha volcado a los franceses A las calles
en jornadas de manifestaciones masivas
que no se veían desde la crisis de los
chalecos amarillos que enfrentó el
presidente Hace cuatro años
el mandatario comparó las escenas
violentas con la toma del Capitolio de
Estados Unidos o el asalto a los poderes
en Brasil para macron a los sindicatos
les faltaron propuestas para negociar
sobre el documento
ayudamos mucho durante la pandemia y
todo se desajustó en este tiempo por eso
se requiere ahora mucha responsabilidad
mucho tiempo pagamos para que la gente
no trabajara para proteger al país y
ahora debemos reajustarnos sobre la
primera ministra Elizabeth World que
está siendo presionada por los
parlamentarios a renunciar dijo que
tiene su completo apoyo y que ella tiene
la capacidad de liderar el equipo de
gobierno Mientras tanto se espera que
este jueves los sindicatos salgan a una
novena gran jornada de manifestaciones
en contra del gobierno que aseguró que
espera que la reforma entre en vigor
para final de año